you all brought four different versions
of the same dish it's
called
okay
this dish and you're gonna try each
other's dish and you're gonna rate it
out of 10 and we'll see which one is the
best i'm rithi hey i'm nick i'm mary hey
i'm robert i was born in cambodia
philippines so i was actually born in
dallas texas born and raised i was born
in phnom penh cambodia but raised in
boston massachusetts i was born and
raised in a seattle suburb called renton
i've only ever had this dish made by my
mom i've never had anywhere else her
recipe is not library traditional she
kind of have our own thing that's kind
of a python generation and i think that
might be a bit different than like
traditional ones so it's really really
cool to see it made by someone else and
see how it tastes like i've eaten it a
bunch you know growing up it was
definitely interesting bringing it
together so hopefully you guys enjoy it
but i'm more curious to see how you guys
approached it i'm actually very curious
and excited to see how everyone
approached it
so this is my take on caco normally this
is eaten with rice noodles rice or bread
and because of bread instead of just
using baguette i decided to make a
gaggle pizza so i made this from scratch
so this dough is a 48-hour cold ferment
dough very high hydration that's how you
get the nice puffy crust even got the
char on the bottom kind of inspired by
the mexican viria pizza i've made the
berry pizza a few times as well
and it kind of reminded me of the
vietnamese ball call which is why i got
inspired to make this version the
ingredients are quite similar between
this kind of beef stew and the mexican
birya herbs and aromatics are a little
bit different using traditional khmer
herbs like galangal lime leaves
lemongrass they actually do use the new
mexico chili as well there's meat in
here flank there's also tripe and
there's also tendon there's also carrots
in here to give that sweetness thinly
sliced onions and cilantro and basil
really brightens up this dish since it's
a pretty strongly flavored dish i don't
know if it's accurate but i hope it's
accurate this is exciting it looks good
the color looks really nice i guess
you're just supposed to dip it
really very good i think it should be a
little bit more sweeter i can taste the
cinnamon star anise comes through it's
very tasty it's like a really
interesting flavor i love the i don't
know the name for something to call it a
pizza bread did he make the pizza though
he made it from scratch good lord coco
pizza i don't know if you're explaining
it this is crazy he literally took this
and put it on a pizza impressive very
oily though i guess it's supposed to be
like that i can tell
he put a lot of thought into it the
meat's very tender that's good she might
have another piece actually does taste
like taco which is really interesting
yeah overall this is really good i'll
give this like a seven out of ten very
solid dish coffee is supposed to be more
like thicker and sweeter but this is
almost like a stew eight out of ten
because of the pizza like this is so
creative to be able to just take these
uh the taco and put it on a pizza
overall it's like a really good dish he
can get an onion just like that little
aftertaste at the end which i think is a
starry nice like comes through a little
bit too much i don't feel like it should
be there
one of my favorite dishes to eat is pho
and i make it all the time so i started
off making it like a fa so i did my own
like beef stock you know roasted the
bones got that ready for it so i just
caramelized a bunch of sugar added the
aromatics ginger the star nice got that
coated added some marinated beef what my
mom told me is you use tomato paste and
tomatoes and you cook it for so long
that the tomatoes basically evaporate
and that's where you kind of get like
the red color let it cook and simmer and
then there's also some carrots in there
it's very hearty it's kind of chilly out
right now you could have with vermicelli
noodles but we're serving it here with
just a baguette i'll leave it to
everyone else to judge and see how they
they do it yeah this definitely looks
like taco the garnish make it look like
a cathedral already all right let's see
it's pretty good pretty tasty a bit more
sour than i expected from tomato asum
which is also a problem mine had i like
the flavor a lot it made a little bit
too
you skimmed a lot of the the fat off the
top i do like a little bit of the oil
for the red color it's much sweeter than
the last one which is what i like and
what i think the dish is typically
supposed to taste like the real test is
how does it go with bread
it has the sweetness a lot of still have
like a flavorful to it the garnish kind
of maybe like a deal but it's okay it's
still very good i do prefer a little bit
thicker if it's going to be diplo's
bread this is pretty watery i like this
one a little bit better than the last
one the meat is tender it doesn't have
much flavor but the texture is pretty
good i will have to give it a nine out
of ten this is actually very close to
authentic so i know i gave the last one
a nine because of the pizza but
flavor-wise i'm gonna go back and give
the other one a seven and this one an
eight instead i do prefer a much richer
flavor and thicker broth five out of ten
it is a bit too sour very very good
this is cocoa i try to make it as
authentic as possible to my mom recipe
throughout my childhood i eat this a lot
you slowly start with a bone broth to
just kind of get like that stock and
then with the tomato kind of cook it
over a long period of time and that's
what give it the red color potato onion
carrot ox tail for like the broth stock
cocoa is supposed to be very sweet so
there's a lot of sugar i only make this
over like two hours as opposed to like
six i think i got the textures right
which is supposed to be very thick
especially when you eat it with bread as
opposed to more watery type where you
would eat it with vermicelli or rice
this looks stewie looks like another
taco would like to see more green on top
or onions as well there's a lot of
solids in here rather than soup chef
likes it thick
the meat doesn't really have much flavor
it's a strong taste of carrots and
onions it's very like watery and not as
much flavor it's really light so it's
nice now this to me feels more like the
vietnamese version of it it's really
good broth though i like it definitely
more on the sweeter side rather than
sour i think more incorporation of
fattier cuts of meat would help as well
it is pretty lean in terms of it's not
greasy it's just lacking flavor but
overall like the texture of like the
vegetables and the meat is okay it's not
like great i'm gonna give it like a five
i'm like just really enjoying it
actually i'm giving nape all the
components are really good potatoes
carrots beef really good very dippable
good broth light it's missing that that
boldness i would like more depth than
boldness four out ten it's a little weak
in terms of flavor
my dish is very special it is like a
concoction of curries i flew in last
night from la and i didn't have like the
resources to make the dish so i tried to
find like the closest dish that i could
so i like ordered like a masamon curry
and it ended up being like green chris
had red curry for lunch so i tossed some
red curry in there with it as well just
so i could get somewhat of like a
similar color to the other dishes so the
only option that they had on the menu
was
chicken or shrimp so i got chicken but i
may just like toss in one of their
pieces of beef in there just to like
throw them off guard i think one of the
guys left their dishes over there yeah
they wouldn't know
hey go for it girl
yeah so hopefully it's good i have no
clue what it tastes like it's nice and
creamy looking this is interesting this
is like a curry what special ingredient
did she add to this one color's
different but it's got the thickness the
consistency this is not cocoa but it
does smell good
[Music]
okay this is very different beaver's
kind of lacking it's a little dry it's
very sweet it's sweet like cocoa but
coconutty and it's so creamy i've had
this before it tastes more like thai
food well i think it is thai food guys i
think we went bamboozled this isn't coco
but they tried their best it's good but
you have to say this is not authentic
cocoa maybe it's a family recipe i don't
know give it a six out of ten it's just
for the good dish given the
circumstances six being really nice
it's not the assignment so i can only
give like a one out of ten as a soup or
curry it's pretty good but it's not coco
this does not take me back to my
childhood
well done everyone so i'm just gonna
read off the scores so in last place
with the average score of 4.3 we have
mary
in almost last place we have an average
score of 5.7 and that is rithi
we actually have a tie for first place
with an average score of 7.3 for both
dishes it is well nick and robert yeah
ty so
man
i mean i'm not gonna act like i don't
want to win but i'm very happy with the
result especially going into competition
unsure of what the hell is supposed to
taste like so i'm just happy he mined it
well and it was accepted cup half full
across the board so yeah that's why i
felt like i had to bring all my skills
here with the pizza and everything
[Music]
you